[Music]
hi there Heather again and hi I'm Morgan
a product manager on spectrum so keeping
tabs on your apps and dealing with
errors can involve multiple tools from
multiple vendors and this is far from
ideal and you really want all the tools
you need in one place right absolutely
which is why on this episode we'll be
talking about stackdriver a one-stop
shop for all the DevOps services on GCP
we'll also run through a quick demo of
the self-paced lab where we'll show you
how to monitor a GCE VM instance with
stackdriver stackdriver provides
powerful monitoring logging and
diagnostics for apps across cloud
platforms it equips you with insights
into your health performance and
availability of cloud powered apps
enabling you to find and fix issues
faster that's right
setting up system level and app level
monitoring is one of the most common
DevOps tasks which makes monitoring one
of the key features the stack driver so
let's take a look at monitoring first
stack driver monitoring collects metrics
events and metadata from GCP AWS and a
variety of common application components
you can then create alerts and
dashboards on this data next let's take
a look at logging in errors
stock driver logging allows you to
filter search and view logs from your
code and your clouds provider services
you can also export these logs into
bigquery cloud storage and pub/sub for
further analysis stack driver error
reporting monitors your applications
errors aggregates them and then alerts
you to any new issues that arise you can
use the error reporting console to see
data about the instances of these errors
the versions of your app in which they
occurred and when they were first or
last seen
APM is a new brand that we're using for
our tools aimed at developers and
root-cause analysis these three tools
can be used on applications running
anywhere including GCP AWS asher or
on-premises the first is stack driver
trace which is our distributed tracing
tool it allows you to view how requests
propagate across all of your services so
you can improve their latency it also
analyzes these traces to inform you how
about latency trends over time or across
different versions of your code stack
driver debugger is quite magical it
effectively enables production
breakpoints so that you don't stop or
slow down customer interactions with
your service debugger can also add log
statements to your production code
without requiring redeployment this is
very impressive tool that we use every
day at Google and we're excited to offer
you the same functionality stack driver
profiler was just launched at the beta
it allows you to see how your code
executes in production giving you
insight into CPU or memory hungry
functions so that you can improve
performance and reduce your costs time
again for quick labs this hands-on lab
will show you how to monitor a compute
engine VM instance with stack driver
you'll also install monitoring and
logging agents for your VM you can check
out the link to start the quick lab here
keep in mind that the lab will take
about 40 minutes to complete at this
point in the lab you've created a
compute engine instance and apache HTTP
server for the instance you've created a
stack driver account for your project
and you've created an uptime check and
alerting policy so let's create a chart
for CPU load create a chart for received
packets on network name your dashboard
of the two new charts test the check and
alert by stopping your instance note the
incident notice on the monitoring
overview page and stack driver view the
logs for your VM by clicking on stack
driver logging well there we have it we
hope you enjoyed this episode on stack
driver don't forget to keep visiting our
on-air webinar series quick labs and our
blogs all the links are below you can
also learn more about stack driver
through our Google cloud on-demand
courses on Coursera thanks for watching
and we'll see you soon
ever wondered how you could automate
triggers in your app
well check out last week's episode where
we demo a clog function